je voudrais démarrer cette émission par
cette terrible nouvelle qu'on a appris
jean pierre bacri un des acteurs les
plus appréciés en france est décédé
aujourd'hui des suites d'un cancer je
sais que benjamin où c'était un grand
fan très proche de lui
alors on voulait absolument lui rendre
hommage et vous m voilà que des trucs
voilà qui nous ont fait kiffer de jean
pierre bacri ce soir on se rappelle tous
bien sûr de 10 10 le film d'alain chabat
une deux une des scènes cultes de dj ou
didier est un chien alain chabat
regarder et maintenant vous allez
pouvoir nous en parler après spa alors
je suis tout à fait d'accord
bon bien sûr on la connaît mais il faut
connaître plus pour sortir le cuir
elle c'est la boulangère elles vont le
pain le pain
bon ou bi oublie le parent est pas
important ça on ne sent pas le cul on
ressent pas le cul des filles ouais
sauf si celles qui demandent si celles
qui demandent tu vois à laquelle voilà
il est incroyable franchement voilà un
ton incroyable je les connais alors j'ai
connu en 1981 parce que ma mère jouait
au théâtre avec lui donc ce n'était pas
encore le grand bacri qu'on a connus
mais mais déjà à l'époque mois d'août
mais dix ans je le voyais les maisons
étaient là tout le temps et il était
j'ai rarement vu un mec aussi drôle que
ça et même du haut de mes design faisait
rire et voilà c'est un mal j'ai eu la
chance de le côtoyer voilà pendant
presque presque un an presque un an
ainsi ce qu'il était comme il était au
théâtre ensemble
il était très élégant il ya un an et 1
élite est très drôle aussi dans les
guignols parce que c'était devenu une
des marionnettes culte des guignols et
on retrouvait notamment en train
d'engueuler des footballeurs regardez
cet extrait très fort comme vous êtes
quand même eu une belle bande de losers
je vous le redis une fois pour toutes
vous allez vous coordonnez et jouer
collectif sheikh battus le ramène pas
ses taux plein les autres pourront
tondre votre politesse c'est la vitrine
de notre pays
donne moi ça toi nous fatiguent luc
situe là oui nicolas pernikoff vous
semble regarder ce qui se passe
non mais c'est un grand acteur qui qui
qui nous quitte effectivement et c'est
un personnage assez simple et accessible
donc c'est vrai que c'est toujours un
peu surprenant et puis je trouve que il
ya beaucoup de gens qui partent en ce
moment donc c'est un peu un peu
difficile en tout cas pour notre
génération ils partent un par un alors
il ya eu un air de famille en 96 jean
pierre bacri retrouve sa partenaire
préféré c'est bien sûr un mj oui on
voulait revoir la scène du bas et ce
sera demain soir
sur ces huit voix là puisqu'on lui
rendra hommage en prime time il y aura
un air de famille sur ces huit
exceptionnellement regarder je passe
pourquoi moi six arrivées qu'elle n'est
pas là
pour l'imbécile qui sait pas tenir sa
femme ouais ouais je suis papa pas moi
certains pas me laisser marcher sur les
pieds comme lui trop bon trop con mais
ça n'empêche pas de les merlettes je
laime mais faut pas exagérer me trouve
déjà 3 aux gentils moi je vais te
répondre à sa place moi si tu veux ouais
bah tu peux me raconter tout ce que tu
veux moi je sais qu'un homme c'est un
homme une femme seule femme
chacun son sexe et les vaches seront
bien gardées oui tu veux tu as girafe où
il jouit women a remonté il a obtenu
quand même quatre césars il faut le dire
du meilleur scénario original il ya eu
ce mot king de smoking dallas rennais
est également on connaît la chanson il
ya eu un air de famille le goût des
autres et il a toujours joué opus au
cinéma c'était année le bourgault il
faisait le râleur alors que quand vous
le rencontriez c'est un mec avec un
regard tellement de temps mais tellement
gentil c'était vraiment un personnage
les contrôles de la radio un jour ils
tireront très très très simple moi c'est
moi j'aime bien aussi ce gars là et
j'avais regardé dernièrement le sens de
la fête avec la nouvelle génération
alban ivanov gilles lellouche plein de
jeunes comédiens jeu tu l'as vu aussi et
il est donc dans le bas cri qu'on est
mort à l'heure où il est il a une
société d and regardez un extrait des
chances de la fête c'est en 2017
j'ai dit on se coordonne
y a personne qui comprend que je joue ma
vie moi à chaque soir et je joue ma vie
je n'ai gala ce soir qui n'est pas
déclaré je ne vais pas la main comme ça
à lever la main juste comme ça
wallace maximum aux seynois avait quand
même incroyable ça fait moins gravissime
et un shader enfin il a fait tellement
de ses élèves il disait un truc de lui
qui était juste merveilleux il disait je
suis pour rien si ma tronche fait la
tronche c'est ça il avait
caractéristiques il est tout sauf un
ballast est magique
alors il a reçu notamment un césar du
meilleur acteur dans un second rôle en
98 pour on connaît la chanson et
regarder pour le discours il avait fait
assez répétitive le césar est attribué à
jean pierre bacri dont jean-pierre
d'accueil qui a déjà reçu deux césars
comme scénariste pour smoking no smoking
en 81 kg 1
pour un air de famille
l'année dernière
voilà pourquoi je dis agnès tu vois
c'est ça quand même d'envoyer des fleurs
et des chocolats tous les huit ans et à
part ça bravo à jamel c'est le premier
critique qui me fait rire voilà en tout
cas je remercie tout le monde voilà et
moi je voudrais avoir un truc où la vé
dir éternels râleurs éternel e books ont
atterri moi je me rappelle d'une scène
culte dans le grand pardon d'alexandre
arcady regarde il ya une affaire de
cerise et de poker regardes tu prends ta
manette
arrête un peu tu prends ta mallette tu
changes les billets entre des plaques tu
joues tu jouais surtout du père quand
comment je perds je comprends plus rien
mais tu perds bourricot bien sûr tu
perds mais le casino il à qui il est à
nous donc tu gagnes et tu ton argent tu
l'a blanchi bin alors tout la jambe avec
ses noyaux de cerises des choux
lachenaud ue allez c'est une des scènes
cultes
de ma mère voilà je vous le dis à chaque
fois me l'apprenez en exemple et chaque
fois il me dit c'est vrai que tu me fais
penser souvent à jean pierre macchi dont
le grand pardon ma mère va devoir garder
et doit se dire c'est vrai qu'elle me
dit à chaque fois elle m'a combien de
programmes et on m'a dit tu nous fais
chier une taie cerise exactement voilà
jean pierre bacri qui va énormément nous
manquer immense et marie jeanne mance
réalisateur c'est l'immense acteur qui
nous a quittés aujourd'hui